titi que c'était aujourd'hui que jean
luc mélenchon a lancé son parti dans la
bataille des européennes une nouvelle
fois il n'a pas été tendre avec le ps et
a tendu la main à olivier besancenot
reportage de véronique gaurel eric
genest photo souvenir le jour de la
naissance d'un nouveau parti
une naissance c'est la suscite forcément
des espérances
moi je crois que la gauche retrouve du
souffle leurs troupes de l'anp vie et
retrouve de lait coûte peu près des
citoyens acquis soit le trait d'union
qui
m à la gauche de s'unir et de prendre le
pouvoir et de mettre en place et à
quatre mois après avoir claqué la porte
du ps jean luc mélenchon et son nouveau
parti ont un objectif les européennes et
une ambition faire mieux que le ps pour
cela ils rêvent d'un fonds commun de la
gauche mais pour l'heure une seule
alliance a été scellé avec le pis si on
est très heureux que jean luc mélenchon
parti de gauche j'ai répondu à l'appel à
l'unité pour les élections européennes y
as le début front de gauche pour changer
d'europe
on espère colisée vance ne va entendre
l'art la main tendue plus épais et
surtout qu'on sera très nombreux et
qu'on conteste le libéralisme en ordre
alors jean luc mélenchon appelle lui
aussi à olivier besancenot et son
nouveau parti le npa sur la base du non
de gauche au traité européen de 2005
il exhorte ali rejoindra irons-nous
chacun avec sa petite pancarte faisant
valoir la nuance du rouge qu'il propose
camarades nous vous tendons la main sans
conditions sans préalable ne la rejetez
pas fait que tous ces événements
finissent par fusionner en un processus
unique celui du changement du
rassemblement de l'unité pour que la
france passe à la république sociale la
main tendue vers olivier besancenot
avant le poing levé et en arrière-plan
ce sont des juges qui les fait tous
rêver plus de 14% des voix aux
européennes
si un front commun de gauche se
constituer
aulas